[Music]
what is a woman
can you tell me that
[Music]
well you're at the women's march you
must have some idea please if one person
can tell me what a woman is you are not
here for women we ask you to leave what
is that
i'm a husband i'm a father of four i
host a talk show i give speeches i write
books i like to make sense of things a
woman is not anything in particular
there is not one particular thing it
could be many things to many people some
women have penises right some men have
vaginas i like scented candles i've
watched sex in the city yeah how do i
know if i'm a woman that's a great
question you're not a scientist you're
not a gender studies major no how do you
know that you're a man i guess because i
got a dick
can a man become a woman
i'm not a woman so i
i can't really answer that women only
know what women are are you a cat no can
you tell me what a cat is
you want to tell us what a woman is
i'm a biological woman
that medically transitioned to appear
like a male i will never
be a man and so they go on the internet
and they're told that all their problems
will be solved if they become a man so
you worry that there there could be a
sort of social contagion element of this
a teeny tiny bit maybe it got me at 42
your child doesn't have a chance
and you're affirming it with hormones
that have never been used in this way
puberty blockers which are completely
reversible completely reversible one of
the drugs used is lupron right which has
actually been used to chemically
castrate sex events
you know what i'm not sure that we
should continue with this interview you
don't want to talk about the drugs that
you give to kids or
how can they be removing the healthy
breasts of 15 year old girls there are
masculine girls they're feminine boys
what are we going to do about that carve
them up how can this whole thing be
happening matt
i wanted us to have a safe place to be
able to talk about this part of me wants
to ask why you care so much i care about
the truth i care about children i care
about the women who are having their
opportunities stolen from them is it
transphobic to tell the truth the
interview is over let's turn off the
cameras excuse me they're fair i just
wanted to know what is a woman and
you're not going to find out based on
what i'm saying would you ever want to
move to america
they say no
never
[Music]
i hope you enjoyed it a little bit
we'll see when it comes out
you